hello
i'm danielle dimartino booth and you are
watching down the middle with d martino
booth i am so pleased today to have with
me
brigadier general robert spalding he is
a senior fellow
at the hudson institute but he has also
just started
a new venture he is the founder of q
networks
and we're going to start off by uh by
asking him what he's doing
with that what what that is what the
future is and then we'll go all the way
back to where it started
thank you it's good to be here so q
networks is really an
extension of what i was doing at the
white house i did a infamous study
on 5g that was leaked to the media on
behalf of the telecom industry so thank
you telecom industry
and is really calling for a nationwide
secure
5g network because the biggest challenge
we face as a nation
is security of our data and so q
networks is really dedicated to
building secure 5g networks so that's
that's what i'm doing now and
it's actually been going for two years
we've completely redesigned
the entire 5g architecture we have a
brand new
industry unique core and we're going to
go to market next year and it's going to
be fun
yay that's what we want to hear and we
will get to that and we will build up to
that
but take us back first i like to talk to
people i have a lot of degrees at least
i thought
i had a lot of degrees until i saw your
resume
you clearly think education is very
important
i lost track at both hands and 10
you kept going tell us about
education in america the challenges we
face
why you find it to be so critical
and what the challenges
kind of are leaving education behind if
i can say that
has presented for us going forward well
i mean
this is a great topic just personally
because my son recently graduated
with honors at mizzou in computer
science
and in his category where he graduated
he was the only american every single
other student
was from china and that's
consistent around the country where you
know our stem
programs just aren't being filled by
american students
they're being filled by foreign students
30 of which are chinese over
152 000 i think was the last count on
just on the chinese students but this
goes back to
you know what we value as a nation and
what we
haven't valued particularly since the
end of the cold war is stem education
because
if you value those things you know most
of our engineers and scientists
particularly those who worked on the
space program
were engineered on or were were schooled
on the basis of federal grants
because the government knew that we
needed scientists and engineers for the
space race so we were actually
when we think of you know national
security and our investments
you know one of the things i've never
heard in a 27-year career in the air
force
you know all focus on national security
is the concept of opportunity costs
right right and so you know one of the
one of the things that brings up
right so so fast forward i'm in the
white house and
we have a 40 to 60 billion dollar bill
every single year in afghanistan so i
asked
one of the people that worked for me i
said can you just give me 10 things that
you could do with that money
one of the things that she came up with
is you could educate
200 000 american kids with
four-year stem degrees and you could do
it every single year so think about
being in afghanistan 20 years the amount
of scientists and engineers
that we could have changed trained but
you know so opportunity costs what do we
spend money on and clearly that is
a multi-generational conflict that has
gone
nowhere right and if you think about it
what we have trained
those kids to do is to destroy things
right to kill i mean
and when you think about the cold war we
we tend to kind of focus on nuclear
weapons
but what we don't focus on is the
economic development that we were doing
that led to the peace that's the piece
that we don't focus on
and it's critical and i think that we're
going to have to
i don't know how we're going to change
the narrative i don't know how we're
going to change the dialogue
but i think i i think we're going to
have to go there um
let's let's step back and kind of
get to why it's so important uh you've
lived in china and
from the perspective of somebody who
follows the financial markets who
follows economics
the government is very planned
in how it presents its economic data
how how organized is this how important
is it what is the communication why is
there such a scripted
narrative when it comes to how china
presents itself
on the economic stage globally well
you know it's a scripted narrative
because if you're in
the chinese government you get promoted
on the basis
of the economic growth that comes from
your
whether it be province or city and so it
those
metrics are tied to your performance
evaluation
which is tied to your career so as you
know
you know everything that gets measured
are the things that people pay attention
to and in china it's
you know it's just the norm that you
fudge the numbers and so
you know it's the only nation in the
world as you know that can predict what
their growth rate's going to be
within a you know a a digit or two
um every single year so i mean this is
why it's it's about it's about careers
uh particularly for the chinese
communist party officials uh and how
they progress through the ranks and so
the numbers have to be
um have to be good for them
so um what does it mean
uh because it's really a big deal for
people who follow
global economies and there are a lot of
implications
for other countries
who have uh that have relied on china
for literally decades and decades as
china has come on to the world stage as
china has built out its infrastructure
what are the implications uh for the
world and there there is a
there's an economic angle here and
there's
also very much a geopolitical angle that
china has
declined to what they tell us is a
three-decade low in terms of
the growth that they're producing
because they they china has been
at the margin the driver of global
growth
for decades now but what does it mean
because their government has to know
what it truly is but what we know
publicly
is that china has slowed to a 30-year
low growth rate
right well um you know
first of all let's talk about the system
that they've built because i think
that's important
as we know access to capital is what
drives
economic growth and so what the chinese
communist party has done so
so you know in china there's two
constitutions there's the chinese
communist party constitution
there's a people's republic of china
constitution
we've mostly focused on the people's
republic of china
or not constitution
and when when you think of the people's
republic of china as the sovereign
then you get this image of this
democratic republic
but in reality because there's two
constitutions the one that's actually
the sovereign is the chinese communist
party so what does the chinese communist
party control they control
the military they control the borders
they control the police and they control
the banks
and so and and really of those the most
important
are the banks and so if you go from the
standpoint that
access to capital is what drives
economic growth
and you have a regime that has basically
created a system
that uses access to capital to get what
they want in other words
they incentivize behavior that is in
their own interests
and that behavior is wealth creation
and economic growth then you can create
a lever that allows you in a globalized
world where we have free markets where
we have an open financial system global
financial system
it allows you to basically take control
of that
and you take control of it not just for
you because you mentioned geopolitics
not just for economic growth but also
for geopolitics
also for social control this is the
power so and
this is why by the way during the cold
war
we did not allow the soviet union to be
embedded
in our in our multilateral democratic
system
it was only after the end of the cold
war we said okay you guys come all in
we're gonna we're gonna bring you into
this arrangement and then you're gonna
democratize because you're gonna see
it's such a
such a such a wonderful benefit for you
and your people well
you know totalitarians don't think that
way and they're like
wait you're going to let me into your
house at the fox into the hen house this
is so awesome
the refrigerator is full and i can come
and do whatever i want and essentially
that's what they did and so
so when you take that
and then you then you back up to the
first quarter of 2018.
so the first quarter of 2018 is when the
national security strategy which comes
out in december of 2017
begins to be implemented in earnest in
other words
all of this hey come on in use the
fridge do whatever you want
pretty soon there's a padlock on the
fridge pretty soon that you know
you're restricted and what you can do
and where you can go that
the federal government begins to close
down on that
part of that is the and i remember
there was absolutely nobody to believe
that we were going to put tariffs on
china
and so part of that is is beginning to
close
access to certainly the u.s and then go
work on a bilateral basis with allies
and partners to say
okay we're closing the refrigerator
we're restricting their access
we think you should too and in fact if
you want to have
access to our military protection
this is going to be a requirement going
forward so now we're fully three years
into that
implementation process and so you're
beginning to see
you know it's not about the chronovirus
it's really about the
the the slow constricting of access in
the
very same way that the soviet union was
treated during the cold war so
you're basically seeing a shift a
geopolitical shift
into a more recognition from a unipolar
world to a bipolar world
not a multi-polar world which is what
everybody was kind of predicting that
we're going to go from a unipolar world
to a multi-polar world
i think in reality it's a bipolar they
would like that yes but it's a bipolar
world
where china and the us kind of lead are
the lead
uh you know planets i guess in their own
orbital system
they are the superpowers and even if you
think of
germany for example as being kind of the
third largest
economy in the world it's neck and neck
with japan right now
germany is the economy that it has
become because its manufacturing machine
has largely become dependent upon
china right so it wouldn't be where it
is right now if it wasn't for that
symbiotic relationship in between its
industrial base
and the needs of its main customer if
you think about it that way
but on more on a geopolitical level
you know the imf right now is involved
in
bailing out i want to say 74 countries
worldwide and you know i get
people who follow me closely know that
if if you call this the corona
virus recession i just my fangs come out
because it's not it is a black swan
economic event that exposed a lot of
leverage
right and in many cases a lot of these
countries that are being bailed out by
the
imf were aided and abetted in becoming
as over
leveraged as they are via chinese banks
and i doubt in a million years that
china figured it was going to end
this way that they were going to be
under a microscope
in the year 2020 being told by world
authorities to stand down
and that they cannot collect on their
debts because these countries are on
their knees
in many ways because so has the quiet
colonization
gone awry and are we paying enough
attention to this because this is
this was a big part of their grand plan
right well i mean so
bring the world bank into it i don't
know if you remember but world bank
basically signed up
to in perpetuity giving them a billion
dollars giving the chinese a billion
dollars
because of just like every just about
every other international institution
the world bank's been
taken over by the chinese no i don't
think they were expecting this
that being said you still have hundreds
of billions of dollars
making their way into china through the
ipos that are
going on in hong kong expunge just did a
billion and a half ipo
on the new york stock exchange despite
having stolen technology from apple and
tesla
and then you've got the chinese bond
market is booming
so so it's not just about the imf
wall street london berlin they're all
sending money
to china and that's what's kind of
feeding this thing so i don't think it's
stopped
quite yet the door because the door
hasn't shut yet
and that's really the thing if this belt
and road initiative
was to rely solely on the currency that
the chinese communist party could create
that i think does less than two percent
of transactions globally correct
even today um they would it
they would that would fall apart in a
heartbeat what they need
is hard currency because hard currency
gets them the raw materials and
resources
that allows them to continue on the belt
and road initiative so this is our big
problem
and it's one of those things where i
keep saying you know the first thing you
do is you find yourself in the bottom of
a hole
is to stop digging right and yet
and and we know the power and the lure
of investment banking fees
uh but when you think when you think
about what's happened in hong kong
and the situation and how it has
evolved why on earth would
they even risk cutting off
such an important international conduit
to their own liquidity
well that i mean that's a good question
i don't think that they do
find that at risk because here you have
a country where there's effectively been
a
you know one country to system policy
that clearly
said no we're going to have one country
one system
we have said state department has said
you're no longer sufficiently autonomous
but yet how is the fed in the treasury
year acted the hong kong monetary
authority still produces a hong kong
dollar still exchanges it
for the us dollar so in effect
the chinese communist party has two
currencies they have what is considered
you know a freely exchangeable currency
in the hong kong dollar
this is how they get hard currency
and then when you when it gets into the
mainland exchanged by uh
by the people's bank of china for
renminbi and then they take their the
communist party takes their cut the
money goes wherever the
communist party wants it to go you know
when you
raise money on the new york stock
exchange it goes to that company
if a chinese company raises money on the
new york stock exchange it goes to the
people's bank of china
who controls the people's bank of china
right
so that that kind of brings me to
where chinese authorities want to go
next
right now there's there are very few
options
the provinces inside the country
are very weak still it is just the big
three
exporting monsters that are doing well
the same way we talk about there being a
k-shaped recovery here in the united
states
there's an equal k-shaped recovery in
china right now
and they've got a serious issue with
unemployment that we of course don't
know about but we do know about it
what they're doing is going back to
their very old playbook they're
pouring money into infrastructure
spending
they finally stopped buying copper but
they've been buying up iron ore and this
is what they did
this is what they did in the 90s this is
what they did in the aftermath of the
financial crisis but is this just a stop
gap measure
where and what does it imply for
australia
and chile and brazil and other countries
that seriously rely on china
to support their economies
when we know that india is not a viable
next place to go in terms of
a demographically attractive country
that needs to come out of
the third world era in terms of its own
infrastructure but
india's not there yet so what are the
implications for the countries that have
relied on china
for decades now and where does china
really want to be spending its money
today so the belt and road initiative i
think is
is a good indicator of where they're
going
and i think what they're trying to do is
essentially connect resources to
productive capacity
to markets and that's going to be
tightly integrated
with the belt and road initiative which
has a maritime
partner component it has a landlord
component and it has a digital component
and so the idea is essentially to
connect these countries that have the
resources
to the productive capacity of china to
offload some of that quebec conduct
productive capacity particularly in low
value added products in those countries
and create
its you know basically an economic
sphere of influence
that is um paired with a social and
political
system that they are comfortable with
and so what they
what's happening is you know because of
what america is doing in terms of
resetting the way it deals with china
and it's doing so
along with its allies and partners
essentially the democracies are
beginning to come together like they did
during the cold war and they were very
tightly integrated in fact
there was just a um a report talking
about this idea of a technology d10
right the democracies 10 coming together
for artificial intelligence 5g
as it was in uh there's a report coming
out that talks about this
and um has to do with 5g and security
that's going to be the democracies what
what china has in mind is
the emerging market economies and the
other authoritarian regimes so we're
talking about middle east we're talking
about
africa talking about latin america we're
talking about central asia
and you know the the the four horsemen
russia iran north korea and china
so that is what they have in mind and so
this idea of a digital currency goes
right along with half the
undersea cables that huawei has laid
with the digital silk road
the building of 5g networks the ability
to control the populations
using technology that silicon valley
built
all of this is meant to have this
arrangement where kind of china's at the
core
and it and it provides the capital via
you know it's it's the the renminbi
which will be part
so it is a close you know financial
system but it's extending that
firewall for that financial system to
the
countries in its orbit it did so in the
beginning
through bilateral currency exchanges
which
you know they it also did with
democracies those are going to go away
so those currency exchanges are going to
exist and and most likely what i'm
guessing with the
introduction of a digital currency is
that they're going to try to basically
create this
this you know greater greater firewall
with it with a digital currency that
allows this
kind of economic activity in the way
that they've
thought about which is the people in
charge stay in charge
and everybody else are subjects well it
sounds like they're going after
places where they can
where they can take control effectively
right um it
truly sounds like you're talking about
well the word you used before this is
a bifurcated type of future that's being
envisioned
uh between the developed countries and
the less developed countries
it was fascinating to me that australia
went so far
as to head a coalition of countries
demanding an independent inquiry into
the origins of the coronavirus
given that china has done so very much
for australia but i think their their
first recession in 30 years
and the fact that there's so much debt
that's been built up and some of the
buildings that the chinese have come in
and built
are flammable and so i visited australia
for some time
i think they're realizing that it that
it was
a deal that necessarily wasn't
necessarily made with their ally
but you are starting to see
the developed world countries push back
against 5g
but they all seem to be natural allies
of the united states the question is
in the end which which of the two is
larger
which of the coalitions is larger but
see this is the entire
play and this is this is exactly by the
way
so i asked to meet with leo hub before i
left beijing which is
probably kind of presumptuous for a
defense attache
but i wanted to explain you know
what was coming because you know i was
being asked to go back to the white
house to help
you know work on this strategy and
i could see this all entirely in my mind
this competition coming between
you think your system is better we think
our system is better
the problem is you've been taking from
our system to make your system work
what happens when we cut that link how
does your system continue to function
and i think that's where so
access to capital drives economic growth
you can paper over a lot of things
in terms of economic efficiency with
state-owned enterprises
when you when you're taking the mac the
most of the capital access to capital
that's driving
new investment when you cut that
now they have to start to stand on their
own two feet which is state-owned
enterprises
which is you know government control
find control
over oh you know how you're putting
money into them right so it's
it's terribly inefficient we know it's
inefficient we've been giving them money
to run it so it's like
it's like your your neighbors your na
you've got a prius and your neighbor's
got you know
a gas-guzzling humvee but he keeps
coming and taking gas out of your tank
to keep himself going we said hey we're
not gonna so i said hey
let me meet with you and i talked to him
i said you guys have been taking
advantage
of us for for so long but you know i
think it falls on deaf ears
they actually believe that their system
is more efficient
and in in and i think leo knows
that this is not right i think he knows
it's in
it's incorrect but of course xi jinping
is
thoroughly thoroughly convinced that no
this is
this is definitely the way that we that
we want to go forward so
so when you talk about he appears to
have true autonomy he appears to have
con
more control than any leader has in
decades
because he's more communist than any
chinese leader has ever been so he's a
leader of the chinese communist party
you could almost say he is the chinese
communist party if you said
who okay you look at all the rhetoric
who believes this stuff
most fervently that would be xi jinping
which is why he finds himself
kind of uniquely in charge in china is
because he's so
he he so much believes in that system
but the problem is
the system doesn't work it doesn't work
if it doesn't have
us putting innovation technology talent
and capital into it to drive it so when
that
so they actually decided to cut it it
wasn't
it wasn't so we talk about decoupling
now
even in my best day i could not have
you know predicted that that they would
that lil ho would take the 150-page
agreement
that he and lighthizer negotiated go to
zhong nang high
and then have the leadership of the
chinese communist party say absolutely
not
my greatest fear was they were going to
say yes right which would have
put the brakes on on all of this
what they did what they said is no
we we've made it this system works we've
built this belt and road thing we're
just going to separate ourselves because
we have all we need
in the meantime we'll try to you know
before they shut the door completely
we'll try to get everything that we can
but but you can see you can see in the
in the
economies of massachusetts you can see
in the economies of california
that their service exports in other
words bringing chinese into
their universities have suffered i mean
there is a
there is whether it's by the design of
the ccp or not
there is a cultural backlash against the
united states that
that hadn't existed prior to that and i
mean
it brings up the question can they home
grow
their own talent do they have the mits
and we we know that they've got the
focus on
stem education that we should have but
can they take it to the next level can
they build out
a.i capacity can they build out a
better 5g network or as you say
is the reliance on the united states a
linchpin that therefore is going to
become a stumbling block for them going
forward
well the science the soviets had great
technology what the soviets didn't have
was a good economic
system again i think
the the cutting of this linkage between
china and the free world will expose
their economic system so
can they pred today can they produce the
type of people that they need to produce
yeah i think they can
um but my sense is as that tie becomes
cut
and their system begins to close in
upon itself that will not continue so
it's
i think that what we what i'm saying is
we've reached peak china
now it's going to begin to slowly erode
because the system doesn't work
and demographics aren't exactly helping
them either and by the way that's
another part of the belt and road
initiative because
everywhere you go when you look at these
low value-added manufacturing what's
going with it
10 000 chinese citizens so so they're
dealing with their demo
graphics which is primarily heavily
weighted in males
because um of the one child policy and
the tendency to
abort the females so you have this you
know
over leverage in in males and so they're
starting to move those out as part of
the belt and road initiative and
and you see this in africa and you see
it in central i don't think the african
nations necessarily appreciate
uh this methodology if you will
because in terms of organic fundamental
growth for their economies china coming
in
i believe there are a lot more promises
than what is
realized because they're not coming in
and creating jobs they're not coming in
and raising up the education and the
know-how
and the technical capabilities of the
populations of the countries
they're bringing their own labor right
well in
in and this is part of the effort on the
state department to
to in in commerce department to work
with these countries to say
hey look at the contracts that the
chinese are bringing you most of them
say i think all of them say
the laborers have to speak chinese they
don't say they have to be chinese they
just have to speak chinese
and so you know that's one of your many
degrees and you you know it's not that
easy that's right all four but my
children particularly
they're not an easy language yeah and
not for their people and so
and what ends up happening is just like
you're saying you know it ends up being
chinese laborers and so they don't
actually benefit
from it but but who does benefit and
this is really
goes back to the point about access to
capital the ones that benefit are the
leaders of these countries
and so you know when you say well the
people aren't going to be taken care of
well
that's not the chinese don't care about
the people they care about getting
alignment of interest with the
leadership so if you get alignment of
interests
then you know it begins it begins to be
part of this overall system i don't care
what your politics are
you know this is the way a chinese
diplomat would look at it i don't care
what your
politics are can i can i give you some
money and we can be friends
of course that well it works if you
think about that if you think
i i lived in venezuela for a short
period of my life pre-chavez
and if you think about it that's kind of
that's kind of what happens that's
that's really
what the playbook looks like but the
playbook does not end very well
when you end up saying i'm going to
to build out an economic empire by
spreading corruption worldwide
in weak countries well
yes as long as as long as the rest
as long as the rest of us don't keep
throwing our money
and technology and talent and innovation
into it
you're right it's gonna it's it's gonna
end badly it's gonna be end badly for
for
china it's gonna end badly for russia
for iran
it's all gonna end badly it's just how
long does it take for it to end badly
well
okay so you're asking a great big
question here how do you how do you put
a seat belt on wall street
bingo i mean that's what you're that
that's what you're suggesting
well yes and but as you know
you know fiduciary responsibility is
built into our system
but yet somehow the chinese have escaped
any any liability for these for
fiduciary responsibility
and you know again it goes back to the
point you made about
fees for things right and
uh wall street's making enormous fees
and
they're making fees in these countries
that are their targets as well
a lot of them splash onto the front page
of the wall street journal is it you
know there's there's bankers here and
there and they're bribing officials
you're like wait a minute
that is how business is done in our
system
who who monitors who who has oversight
of wall street
and where this is one of the things that
i learned about my whole episode with
the telecom industry
right the industry has enormous control
over dc in terms of their ability to get
the kind of policies they want so you
look at treasury and sec the ones that
should be
reining in this infatuation with china
and they're both tightly tightly
connected to wall street
and so that's what's going on everybody
knows it
and the president you know had to step
in
so that the thrift savings plan the
retirement system
for active duty military wasn't being
invested
in weapons manufacturers in china that
they would have to face so
so that's that's that's where we are
right now if we could break this tie
what i would call a stranglehold of wall
street over
you know the those that are supposed to
do oversight over the industry within dc
then i think everybody would wake up and
realize okay this is insane
we cannot send hundreds of billions of
dollars into this
because first of all just like in
venezuela that money is gone
it's not coming back and it's going to
be
uh put into hard assets that the chinese
want
for the system that they're trying to
build and why
for the life of me i can understand why
we would continue to do this other than
our system is just as corrupt as theirs
in some ways i was about to say greed is
greed is good where where i started my
career and that's going to be something
that's
very difficult to uh it's it's a culture
it really is
shift gears for a minute put your 5g hat
on we're starting to see
some of our allies push back
against huawei push back against their
systems effectively being
infiltrated do you think that we can
turn this
around to where chinese
don't literally have the keys to the
kingdom and the ability to spy on
everybody so
it goes right to the same problem of
wall street and its industry
industry has a stranglehold on on so and
theoretically the city of london
because if you think about it what what
the united states started with this
auctioning of spectrum and the rise of
the of the telecommunications networks
those have essentially become toll roads
toll roads that
the telecom operators maintain
and they were in the beginning it kind
of made sense because
the technology kind of required that you
built
networks this way but as technology
you know evolved we found our stuff and
we find ourselves today stuck on toll
roads
when in reality we could open up this
vast swath
uh you know it's like it's like that
that that scene from the movie
independence day where he's driving
all the rvs across the desert and you've
got this
salt lake you know bed that you're
driving on you have all of this
space that's what that's what we have in
spectrum
that's what technology can actually give
us access today
but the telecom industry says no i want
to keep you on my toll road
and so that's why and the real estate
developers say get rid of the toll roads
that's great property we can develop it
but here's the deal
here's the brilliance of of that whole
idea
it actually plays into huawei because
because they're stuck
on these toll roads and they're in their
rickety
and they they they don't have the latest
equipment
but what incentive do they have to build
on it because they haven't made their
investment back from 4g
right so along comes huawei and says hey
i'll sell that to you
hey i'll give it to you why why
why would they give you the the
infrastructure why would they build it
for you
because what silicon valley found out is
it's not
the toll road it's the data that rides
on the toll
road that's where the doubt the value is
right yeah i mean that's what they want
they want the data
greg greg ipp had a great story in in
the wall street journal a few weeks ago
and he basically plotted out on a graph
and showed that that huawei's got almost
a
third of global telecommunications
equipment
in its possession almost a third if it
gets to 50
it will effectively be globally dominant
and
this is this is the data gathering
equipment that we're talking about here
so so you know the you know the um
stock multiple on att verizon t-mobile
you also know the stock mo
multiple on facebook amazon and google
right they're not
they're not in the same class same zip
code so so one is
one has got toll roads and the other
one's got data
right okay so the chinese look at this
and they say hmm
americans dominated 4g um the guys that
the guys that built the toll roads
didn't make any money but the guys that
took the data and built the app services
and business models on top of those toll
roads
they're the ones that cleaned up
we cannot break into that why because
the two companies that control the
platform for that are apple and google
android and ios now like
even huawei as hard as huawei tried
they could not break into that because
they have they they have the dominant
position
well they're called monopolies for a
reason exactly
so so what did they say they said well
we're not even going to go there
we're just going to go to the next thing
and the next thing is not a smartphone
world
so android and ios don't get to play
right it's about
cameras and machines and everything's
connected so they're just basically
going
and they're they're basically going
doing an end around
and their their business model is this
huawei
you go build the roads baidu alibaba and
10 cent
they'll be the monetization arm right
they'll take the data they'll monetize
it
but it's not just for economic growth
it's also for social and political
control because that's the way their
system is right
and then huawei we'll just force
baidu alibaba and 10 cent to
fund your effort right so make sense
if you were if you were going to do the
same thing in um
here in the united states what you do is
you tax the tech companies
to pay for a new nationwide
you know really great 5g can we do that
well
we could if we wanted to but we don't
we don't want to we want to allow why
can't we want to i mean why can't we
make it a matter of national security to
want to
well i mean we are so you know i get to
i get to the white house and um
my colleagues at the national economic
council when i say hey we need to do
some
industrial policy says um no
america doesn't do industrial policy i
said well you know there's other nations
that do
and we're getting our ass handed to us
yeah because we're not
and so you so the recent congressional
report even that came out from
um the republicans that did a report on
the china study
if you look in the report and you look
at what they did for 5g
there's nothing in there why because the
telecom industry does not want the
federal government
to tell them how to build the next
network oh by the way
they're not actually building the next
network because they're stuck
in 4g they're stuck on the smartphone
and what china did is said okay china
unicom china mobile
i you know in the past we've let you
build your own networks
you guys are going to build one network
and you're going to share it remember
what i said
because the technology now allows you to
open up
vast swathes of spectrum and if you
build
you know more than one physical network
in your country
so think about this you have two
companies
this one has to spend a billion dollars
and this is a notional small country so
he spends a billion dollars
building a telecom network this one
spends a billion dollars
on a telecom network and then they're
fighting for customers
meanwhile the customers get half
the speed
and what else they pay twice the price
so half the speed at twice the price
because the throughput when you break
them up like that in separate
physical networks it doesn't it doesn't
make economic sense so your cap
so for us in the united states our capex
is four times our opex is four times
and our speed that the customer sees is
one-fourth
this is so this is the the
the technology this is what the
technology has given us but our industry
models
today are based on old technology the
chinese
uh you know i'm pretty sure they read my
report and said okay china you come
china mobile you're gonna build one
network you're going to share it
yep and be efficient about it yeah i
mean we don't i mean
in in our family we've got one person
has a t and the other person has verizon
for when we travel
so when one person loses loses coverage
the other person has it
and that's that that's kind of a very
real world example of
of what's taking place um so we're
talking about
money money money money money we're
talking about capital we're talking
about money leading
to control uh on a geopolitical
stage so
is there any merit to what is happening
in the south china sea do we need to be
worried
about taiwan semiconductor about taiwan
about what is happening in
china's military and where we're
eventually going with this
is he who rules the sea and the whole
idea
of reserve currency status
because in the history of mankind going
back to the roman empire
it's never been lost if there's just
been
a currency war or if a currency war has
escalated to a trade war
it's only if you get to that third step
where it escalates to a hot war
that the currency itself is at play
and at risk and but as you just said
less than two percent of global
transactions are being done
however they're looking for a workaround
so i'm curious
if it is just saber rattling or if it's
something that
the world needs to be paying closer
attention to because prior to the
current administration
there were many there there were many
times that
it was brought up before world tribunals
and
and said what china is doing is
in violation of international law and
yet nothing has been done nothing has
still been done
so um south china sea
the the chinese communist party told the
people's liberation army
back in the 70s hey the vietnamese are
starting to move into these
islands in the south china sea we need
to do something about it and pla told
the chinese communist party
we don't have the resources we don't
have aircraft carriers we don't have
that we
we can't sustain any kind of effort down
there because how are we going to fuel
our ships
how are we going to keep them
operational so so
that's in the 70s you know fast forward
to you know 2013
2014 now they finally have
you know the resources and so they start
building the islands in the south china
sea
so the whole point of the islands and
the south china sea is this is fed by
the russians
the technology military the the
in terms of the
helping build the actual aircraft
carriers themselves oh yes but i mean
the in in essence the the the islands
are
just basically aircraft carriers
that don't go anywhere so they so they
basically built islands
stationary aircraft right they're
stationary aircraft carriers because
they can they have dredgers they can
dredge up sand they can make islands the
whole point of that was it was a
long-term strategy by the people's
liberation army to answer what the
chinese commerce party told them which
is
get control of the south china sea so
now they have the islands
they can they have ships down there they
have planes down there and they can
begin to coerce their neighbors and say
this is ours the resources the fish
the the natural gas the oil all of it is
ours and those are international
commercial lanes
nobody nobody can they're actually
according to the chinese there's
it's the chinese lake right they they
own it
so but this is getting to your point
about um
do i think there is a potential for a
hot wheels so
i don't think there is right now but the
risk
is increasing now the the thing that i
think
keeps the chinese at bay from the united
states
is the same thing that keeps the us at
bay with regard to
russia and that's nuclear weapons so
nobody else in the region has nuclear
weapons
so the chinese communist party feels uh
pretty
safe just going around and bullying
their neighbors because nobody has
nuclear weapons no
who is going to oppose them and so
i can expect that you're going to see
more and more of this as time goes on
as you lead into this this question
about
um is there going to be you know
is there going to be a change in the
reserve currency i don't think so
because the chinese aren't willing to
allow their currency to float
and there's no way that anybody's going
to want to take the yuan
if the only way they can exchange it is
to go begging at the people's bank of
china so i don't think that
so are we going to have a war a hot war
between
kind of the united states and china i
don't think so because of nuclear
weapons number one
number two i don't think the chinese are
going to get exchange uh or reserve
currency status
except within that economic sphere that
i talked about with the belt and road
initiative which is very demographically
i mean that's some of the best
demographics in the world that you
describe right
so so and this gets back to the
competition
so when i talk about to people about
what the national security strategy says
it's really about three things protect
and that's really we got to cut that
link
we got to stop that stuff flowing
rebuild okay since
innovation technology and talent's not
going to china now where can it go
the united states other democracies
right and then inspire
and this is really where we get back to
what we're doing the cold work kind of
like the marshall plan right
we take usaid export endpoint bank
trade development agency developmental
finance corporation millennium challenge
corporation
we work with allies and partners and we
begin to
at the same time that we're doing
economic development very much like the
chinese are doing because they have been
very strategic
about how they develop economically but
at the same time we're doing public
diplomacy we're talking about
the values and principles that are that
go with our system
and we do that strategically you know
on the fringes of where the chinese have
basically grabbed territory
because the third part is called inspire
you
inspire the people that are behind the
curtain
by saying we have a better life for you
not only
do we have better economic growth but
you can do it in your way
right you know you're you're free to be
who you want to be right you can meet
your true potential
this is what we were doing during the
cold war we were inspiring people
it wasn't about fighting it was about
showing that we had a better system
a better system for humanity and what
happens is
as you begin to do that as because
when you brought china into the tent the
system began to fall apart and we didn't
recognize it
you know the stock market's growing
people are getting wealthy but
but we quietly learned that lesson in
the korean war others are getting we
just didn't take enough away from the
korean war
right but you know that was kind of a
microcosm of what we're talking about
here which is total systemic collapse
and and so you have to basically begin
to heal that system and as it grows up
and as you
help certain other emerging market
economies that actually want to go a
different way
but you know if you look today in terms
of what usaid does in africa
just look at water congress gives them
water for a certain country
you know you have this pot of money for
a water project
in nigeria for example
because i went to usaid i said what's
your strategy for development in africa
and they looked at me like what are you
talking about
what the chinese do are say identify a
resource
build the way to get that resource
identify a port connect them with roads
and rail telecommunications
power or water now what do they do they
start putting in low value added
manufacturing
urbanization to support the workers that
are that are working in the factories
now you've gotta you know you've gone
from a a
backwater to industrial economy to
information economy
fifty 50 smartphones you're using wechat
10 cent alibaba
all of these companies start to this
begins now you've got an information
economy
and when we do develop populist that's
beholden to you by the way
exactly and so when we you we that's
what we did
if you think about that was a marshall
plan yep it's exactly what we did
except rather than you know
being piece meal like we've been for the
last 30 years
it was focused it was about building the
civil society
at the same time we were building a
comprehensive you know
economic capability that was tied to the
united states
this is we stopped doing that at the end
of the cold war
and at that's the same time the chinese
came in and said
okay you're not going to do that but
that's a great idea we're going to do it
we're going to tie it to our way of
looking at the world and it's worked for
them
beautifully because our business sector
in our
our financial sector has actually been
involved with them
doing that that's what mckenzie when
mckenzie gave me the report
in in the white house that says hey we
should partner with africa or with china
and africa and i'm like
what are you talking about and i asked
him i said who did you interview for
this report
the business owners who are they chinese
who else
the leaders of the countries
authoritarians who else did you
did you interview any of the people i
literally asked them that right they
said
well i asked a taxi driver here and
there
so that is and and you actually get to
kind of the the incestuous nature of
wall street and the and the consulting
firms that they deal with all the time
but it's just it's it's affirmation bias
it's
it's you might as well be conducting
really expensive research inside of a
vacuum
because that's as much value out as
you're going to get out of it sorry
um but you know a country
a country's name continues to pop into
my mind and that is india
it would seem that if there are any
global allies
that are for lack of a better term up
for grabs
that that there is a ton of focus right
now on the potential
in india that by the way has more people
in it than china and they're a lot
younger it would seem to me
that somebody in washington dc
needs to be hyper focused on building a
fantastic relationship
with a country that has always
assisted our service economy
and yeah i have friends who have entire
workforces in india and
and can't speak highly enough about
their work ethic and their
adoption of of the of education
but it would seem to me that in addition
to everybody we consider to be our
traditional
if you want to go back to the cold war
the old cold war
everybody who was on our side then plus
india seems like we've got a fighting
chance
plus there's a lot of for american
companies to go in and do
economically i mean when you think about
the
i'll go back to the korean war for a
minute the japanese economy was on its
heat it was on its knees
but we were occupying it at the time and
we
you know logistically speaking we
couldn't get everything we needed to
fight the korean war so what do we do
we fired up the industrial base in in
japan
and it ended up being a win-win because
japan ended up becoming obviously one of
our
great allies in japan does not trust
china to this day and that's not a bad
thing
but uh but i hate to have thrown a
question at you that you probably
may or may not have an opinion on but it
seems to me that we need to be
strategic in looking at peaceful
countries
with great economic potential um there's
a good book by john pomfret called
um beautiful country and middle kingdom
and it i think it's a great read and it
really tracks this
kind of a love-hate relationship between
us and china and it's really
it's an odd pairing um but
it's been since the beginning of our
country that we've had this
fascination with china we haven't had
of course india was a british colony and
maybe that's
maybe we thought that we had more of an
in in china because
you know india was all britain but
i don't know the answer to the question
but i do know that if we don't get
wall street in the corporate sector as
infatuated with
india as they have been with china
then we don't get anywhere that's the
problem that that
that i see in the government you have to
get the private sector
to to to want to be there and if the
private sector wants to be there
and i'm talking about the u.s privacy
right then you're going to see the money
go there you're going to see the
businesses go there and you're going to
see
and as that relationship strengthens i
think you're going to get the kind of
reaction but
but to to date we haven't
you know even in in what we're doing
with with regard to the federal
government
we haven't got the private sector
enthused about it and
and we don't say china's definitely got
their eye on on india
without a doubt right we don't think
holistically about
strategy we don't think holistically
about
you know how do we cr how do we achieve
our objectives the chinese think
holistically they like
i've got all this economic capability
and i've got military
what do they do they say well i'm gonna
you i'm gonna rely on this this is to
keep
people out of my backyard this is really
to grow my geopolitical leverage right
one system feeds the other right and we
basically
said hey you corporate america wall
street you go off do what you want
we're gonna we're gonna go out and use
these security relationships to kind of
get what we want no it doesn't work
countries want economic growth their
people
need economic growth if we led with that
then our relationship with india i think
would would flourish i agree
india's the natural relationship for the
united states that's democracy for
heaven's sakes
it's not a totalitarian regime they
don't do organ harvesting they don't
lock up uyghurs
you know in in prison camps now there
are some of them say hey well there are
some challenges
well there's challenges everywhere but
compared to china
it it it's there's no there's no vote
but
the only thing that i can say is that we
have had this
you know sort of unnatural fascination
with china
as a nation and i think john prophet
does a good job of explaining that
what i've got a great chart that we can
that we can throw up that shows that
that that within nine years
china is going to have a third of all
semiconductor
manufacturing in the world
what helps us as a nation what helps
us in terms of in terms of building a
government relationship
with industry try and combat
that tide because it seems like we need
to do this
starting in the classroom first of all
starting with our young ones
but all the way up to building better
relationships
with silicon valley with raleigh durham
the next silicon valley
um and but but how are there
efforts are there discussions about
efforts in washington dc to make this
happen because
listening to everything you're saying it
seems like we're just asleep at the
wheel
or the left hand doesn't know what the
right hand is doing i'm not going to
throw a third cliche out there
so we spend 800 billion dollars a year
in defense
um the biggest lobby for
huawei in dc is the semiconductor
industry in america
why because their their talking point is
let us sell chips to huawei they buy so
many that enables us to do r d
that makes us better okay
i think what people have missed is that
the the most powerful semiconductor
company in the world right now is tsmc
it's a taiwan taiwan yeah um qualcomm
doesn't make
um semiconductors they design them
that's only part of the process 70 of
the innovation comes out of the
production process itself
okay so we've lost that capacity to be
the leading
semiconductor producer in the world
taiwan has it
what do we need to get back well again
i'll go back to the coal work because
it's such a great example
we were spending 1.7 percent of gdp on
science and technology
i'm going to go home and watch hidden
figures and um
apollo 13 and armageddon and sit the
kids down and it's
there it's all the strat the strategy
was wonderful
though and it was really started by
eisenhower if you think about it
and what is he he's an army guy says
okay
we can we can fight it out or we can use
our system to beat him well he saw
stalin
and he knew what the capacity was for
potential destruction
and what patience does
in leadership roles and how and that is
that's the role that china's played
china's played the patient
superpower and we're like the
schizophrenic one
in a way well eisenhower what eisenhower
realized is that if we can use our
military to deter conflict
if we can postpone a real war we don't
want to get back into that
and then use our science and technology
and economic growth and our freedom
to and to innovate to really grow up our
society
well then over time we're going to win
right
and what happened was we lost sight of
that and
really at the end of the cold war we
really saw this military as a wonderful
tool
to kind of go and and and and rebuild
the world in our image
and in reality you know that's when
we're at our worst
and what the chinese at the same time
what the chinese had learned from the
end of the cold war is
aha this is not how to fight the
americans
you don't want to get into this kind of
you know
where you're spending on your military
because so you are spending 40
of gdp on the military they said no what
we're going to do is we're going to take
everything they'll give us
right and we're going to build up our
economy in our science and technology
using everything they have because you
know what she
you know wakes up every day in hopes
that
president trump in our congress will
have a two trillion dollar defense bill
if we could just spend two trillion
dollars on defense
xi jinping would get up smiling every
day because he know he's that much
closer to his goal his goal is not to
defeat us militarily right
his goal is to bankrupt us and that's
essentially what
so right you talk to the people that um
i have a friend that helped some of the
sailors
that were stranded in ukraine after the
soviet union collapsed
they're literally starving in their
bases and came in helped them
scrap their ships for money so they
could feed their families
they still have like an annual reunion
where they come and they celebrate this
person for actually
helping them get out of this predicament
that the collapse of the soviet
union left them in when we at the
pentagon when we think about hey what's
the future hold
nowhere in our wildest dreams do we can
we contemplate the day
when the president calls up and says
stand down we don't have any more money
to pay
for food or gas or even to pay your pay
your
payroll but that's what xi jinping
contemplates maybe not in his lifetime
but over time that's what they're going
for they're going for this effect where
we essentially
bleed ourselves out right because we've
we've completely lost this
eisenhower and and what happens when he
leaves office what does he say
beware of the undue influence of the
military-industrial complex what mccain
would call
the congressional military industrial
compromise now unfortunately
mccain was part of the problem it was
this idea that we can grow a military
that will keep america safe in a
globalized internet connected world
when authoritarians are just going to
use the might of america to undermine us
from within
this is where you know you know this is
where the book stealth work comes from
it's just this realization on my part
i'm look i've done national security my
entire life
i i've always thought about strategy and
the big epiphany for me was that
we had it completely wrong and the
chinese had it completely right and if
we didn't fix this
that we're going to be we're going to
end so
and yet somehow we as a nation
are spending trillions of dollars we're
not building out our infrastructure and
having that be
world class we're not
building up vocational training i'm a
huge advocate of vocational training
mainly because my electrician and
plumber
and hvac they're so darn expensive
because they're 40 50 years old
uh we're not getting a return on our
investment and yet
there are so many young americans today
who
would push us in the direction of de
facto socialism
not realizing that such a development
would
make g wake up happy every day
from what you're describing and that is
kind of where we're going
you can you cannot throw money at people
to not work
and yet that will take the country down
if we continue to build
these type of social programs that don't
give us a return on our investment
right you were at the fed there's a lot
of economists at the fed right
and they all advocate for printing more
so this you know economist
but you know i've gone through
neoclassical and looked at
kind of all kinds of economic
disciplines i think
what i've noticed is that most of the
people that make policy in this country
are on the theoretical side
and then when you talk to the guys on
the empirical side they say
um something doesn't
this doesn't fit no and so and there's
no
there's no controlling mechanism to come
in say hey your theories aren't working
out
we need to try something different and
you know we're now we're in this
situation where
um the only option that we think that we
have as a country
and i know you talk about this and write
about this
is to open up the floodgates for money
but
when you when you open up the floodgates
for money in america
and the sluice is built to drive it to
china
then the ability to build infrastructure
the the ability to build manufacturing
the ability to
send your kids to the school they're
taking that
and they're they're it's it literally
comes back to buy
startups high technology startups it
invest in our companies
to send their kids to our universities
to invest in our university
all so that they can get a return on
their on their investment
our money right right the the obama and
we're doing the same thing during the
corona virus by the way that we did
during the 2008 financial crisis which
is
let's let's let's throw this system
throw money at it
and what did it do in 2008 it went to
build cities in china
that nobody lived in and now they're
building more
infrastructure out and they're also
building the belt and road initiative so
so when we talk about the belt and road
mission of in america we don't realize
that just like the
islands in the south china sea we paid
for them
it's our money that's going into them
and it's building china's strength and
you know for the life of me
you know you i talk to congress i talk
to
people in the administration
there's just a disconnect you know
there's there there is kind of
you know there is the mccain system
which i think is
is kind of the standard system that we
have the establishment system in terms
of national security
and i think it's it's it's leading us
down to destruction
right um then and there's another
there's a good book that just came out
uh kill chain by um by um
christian bros i think is his name
worked for mccain
talks about you know the incredible um
backwardness of the american military
and this is what i lived
you know all of these advances in that
silicon valley brought to
the commercial side they never made it
to the military
yes trust me you as a military member
you live in two worlds you live you live
in the world
you have your iphone and you live in the
world of your you know 1972 computer
uh in in the military um we're not
collaborative we're not connected and so
he he
he nails it in terms of the problem in
the military
because we haven't adopted these tools
that silicon valley built
but what he misses is the battlefield
right the battlefield he says
well we need to take these tools and
make become more efficient killers no
we need to take these tools and become
better at implementing them in the world
that we find ourselves getting beaten in
it's not just a world that we've been
talking about economics it's also the
world of influence
social media the ability to take your
data and convince you that something
that you thought was your idea
is actually somebody else's idea and
that's what the chinese
so what silicon valley built which is so
incredibly powerful
is the ability to influence you to do
something
what the chinese communist party figured
out is okay that thing i want you to in
to to do is not just related to
you know a retail or commercial thing
it's also a social and a political thing
it's much more powerful to change the
way people think right so think about
isis
think about isis in in in their ability
to use social media to influence new
adherence
and then think about isis with a 13
trillion dollar economy
that's what we have right they don't
want it it's not about terrorism
it's about adopting their world view and
if they can
slowly influence your kids
you know through tick-tock through all
of these
all of these things yep and as
baidu alibaba in 10 cent gains more and
more data
they gain more and more power if you
think about kaif
have you read ai superpower kaifu lee
must must read book kaifu lee is is
china's
ai kind of okay you know whatever you
call them
profit he says that
their strategy is to become the saudi
arabia of data
because data drives artificial
intelligence again it goes back to
huawei builds the pipes phase baidu
alibaba intensive takes the data
and then they bring it in and they they
execute on
slowly so so there is plan there is
there is kind of the addendum to the
plan where they say they they close up
the emerging market economies
at the same time they're continuing to
slowly erode
you know the belief in the principles
and values of liberal democracy
that's that is their long-term plan
because even if they
they you're not going to let them in
economically if you're going to let them
in
digitally then they're going to begin to
slowly kind of infuse these principles
through your education system through
social media
and in to the extent they're connected
to our global economy
through that as well so international
travel
i don't think is going to be coming back
for a long time and it would seem
that we will have fewer chinese students
in our universities going forward
again there is a from speaking with
people who are in china there is a there
is an american backlash
there so that would that would seem to
be a silver lining of sorts
of the coronavirus the coronavirus is
also
kind of a moment that
i don't think we can turn back from and
my last question is
it it could be
you name it the libertarian candidate
running the country
it could be anybody running the country
in in the coming
can we ever put china
back where it came from back
to where it is a predator
in the united states or to
donald trump's credit will we never be
able
to do that and i'm you know i'm hoping
you have one
of two answers but do you think that
that
weak leadership because most americans
right now are very adamantly
opposed to china this is something that
has been exposed it is part of the
american
psyche now and do you think that that
is going to be remain prevalent
regardless of who's in office
well i guess i wouldn't be here if i
didn't
i mean this is by the way this is why i
left the military
i knew that i would i needed to write
about it i needed to talk about it i
needed to
i needed to you know it had to be a call
to action if we don't stop
what we're the same way that kind of you
wrote
fed up i mean it's we have to wake
people up out of their slumber and now
the problem is the chinese communist
party is
has studied us and they know pearl
harbor they know 9 11.
they know if you get the americans riled
up they're going to come together and
they're going to fight
that's why they chose this strip path it
was it's a very dis
disruptive kind of slowly you know
you know materializing path that is
built
entirely for our psyche which is don't
hit us don't hit us give us a hug
give us a hug i'm your best friend
because that's our nature
and so but we have to wake up from the
summer we have to understand
how the system is going i think if we do
and it's it's all about the so you're
saying
as you say i think you know certainly i
see it in the hill
americans are starting to wake up and
say hey we've got a problem they don't
know what the problem is
right and they don't know therefore they
don't know what the solutions are but
um i think they're starting to now ask
the question it's an awareness
that's where it starts and if we could
now begin to say okay
um theoretical economists that that that
said hey globalization is great for
everybody
um maybe that's not the case and we need
to kind of rethink some of
you know let's become a little bit more
pragmatic and practical
like the chinese and a lot less
theoretical and say okay
this is working this is not working and
and begin to
fix this thing i think it's i think
we're i think we're on the path
i think we're three years solid good
three years
in this thing the biggest thing that i
think if we could if we could cut off
the flow of capital
to china i think you'd see a tremendous
change now
is there are there gonna be um banks
that are taking a haircut
absolutely but they're going to take
more of a haircut if they keep going so
you know i'm i am net positive
i'm bullish on america i'm bullish on
the free free market
because i think we're going to we're
we're we're i mean
i've been to europe the tide has turned
in europe
i know the japanese and the koreans are
like uh you know
china i mean because you asked the
japanese do you want the chinese to
protect you uh-uh
right okay well then so all right so we
have the allies lined up
they're like and and the coronavirus has
if if we need it for them to be more
focused than they were before
you know that the fact that people don't
realize that
that the shutdowns were
overdone for a very simple reason
world leaders were operating in the dark
right they had
absolutely no idea no data in hand
i mean as i've said before they still
don't but we
other than other than what we ourselves
have collected we still don't have
data in hand to this day and this was
all under the
tells you the chronovirus is not as bad
right
as we originally or that it evolves and
that it
and that there are you know clearly
what's happened in china if you see
the packed beijing auto show recently
they've clearly figured out some things
that that they haven't shared with the
rest of the world
but if the coronavirus is not a global
wake-up call i can't say what is i mean
you have all these countries economies
on their knees
so i mean it's like say it's like knock
knock knock leverage is not your friend
look at what's happened because you've
had this event
occur in with with all this leverage
that was built up
in the background we we can't keep
trying to do the same thing and
expecting
a different outcome if we get another
cliche so um
anyways you've you've actually helped me
draw the link between dc
and the fed in one more way that's got
me fed up
so uh you continue on your mission i'll
continue
on mine thank you for spending this in
the middle let's let's meet in the
middle
and let's let's keep the darned american
dream
alive i mean i'm going to go find an old
pen that says i like ike
and wear it and people are going to ask
me about it and you will have inspired
me to tell them the story
so i thank you so much thank you